I met the guy through uh Jim Jeff that
that he said the guy that shot Bin Laden
didn't he just get arrested uh uh uh Rob
Rob O'Neal yes yes yeah I I've met him a
couple times yeah I did I did a comedy
bit on on funnier die where I played the
man who shot Bin lad that's was yeah
yeah yeah yeah so but you met the that's
how I met him yeah I think he heard
about it saw it thought it was funny and
wanted to meet me and so oddly it was at
a Super Bowl party in New York when the
New York Super Bowl happened right and I
just met him at some at a random party
and he was like I'm the guy I was like
you're the guy but isn't that I'm going
to ask you as a marine he keeps saying
I'm the guy he's hanging out with people
he's you're not supposed to say you're
the guy well you you know um I can't
speak for all those the the special
Warfare Community uh they're they're
their own lot and they do their they
have their own you know uh whatever code
of ethics and their own way of doing
business their own standard operating
procedures that's SE team yeah SEAL
Teams and and you know you've got Delta
and you got all kind every service kind
of has their special huya guys uh so I I
don't I don't ever want to speak for
them or or you know I uh I didn't think
they talked about it but you know for
whatever reason he did uh he felt
compelled to and I I I don't know why
but but he did I don't know we'll
see you don't think so I don't know for
a
I didn't hear what you said you
didn't hear what I said I thought you
said we'll see it I yeah we'll see no no
I said I killed Bin Laden
would get you well I you know how the
the reason we shot the whole thing I was
sitting there with uh will frell and
Adam McKay and we were talking about
doing a bit for funnier die right and we
were having a meeting we're just sitting
in a room and it was the day after so
they got Bin Laden on a Sunday night and
our meeting was Monday morning right so
of course we we're not talking about
what we were going to do we all we were
talking about is the fact we got Bin
Laden and was just shooting the you
know talking about it and and we were
talking about God could you imagine if
you were the guy that got Hitler and
you're the guy that got OB like you
never to buy a drink again you never
have to buy a meal like you're going to
be a worldwide hero not just a national
hero but like a real Global hero and you
know then of course men we go and I bet
you you know getting laid be a lot
easier right you know it would be and uh
and so we go oh we got to make a video
about this so that's literally that day
we said scrap whatever we were going to
do let's make a video about the guy who
shop in Laden and uh uh and and we're
lamenting too because we're like and the
thing is is no one ever is going to know
this guy could be standing next to you
in an elevator you'd never know because
they can't talk about it right or they
you know they're they're not supposed to
yeah so uh so anyway that's why we made
that that comedy video about it U and it
was a funny video and and it was quick
too like we we decided on Monday we
wrote it on Tuesday we cast it on
Wednesday and shot it on Wednesday and
it edited Thursday and by Friday it was
out like I mean it was Shang bang bang B
[Music]
p